Eliza comienza a caminar
desde un punto a 5 km de la escuela
y camina alejándose de ésta
a una velocidad de 3 kilómetros por hora.
Estaba a 5 km. de la escuela
y todavía se va a ir más lejos.
La tabla a continuación
muestra la distancia en kilómetros,
de otros estudiantes
a la escuela en varios momentos.
Todas las personas caminan a una velocidad constante
y todas empezaron a caminar en "t" igual a cero.
Así que estas son las distancias
que los separan de la escuela
después de 1 hora, 2 horas y 3 horas
de haber estado caminando.
¿Cuáles estudiantes estaban más lejos de la escuela que Eliza cuando empezaron a caminar?
Entonces esencialmente lo que quiero hacer,
es descubrir, cuál es su distancia
cuando "t" es igual a 0
y compararla con la distancia de Eliza.
comencemos con Gordon,
Gordon cuando han pasado 2 horas,
estaba a 2 kilómetros de la escuela
y cuando había pasado 1 hora,
estaba a 4 kilómetros de la escuela.
Vamos a encontrar su velocidad,
la tasa de cambio de la distancia
con relación al tiempo.
Cuando transcurre una hora...
cuando transcurre una hora,
Gordon ha pasado de haber estado
a 4 km. de la escuela,
a haber estado a 2,
su cambio neto en la distancia fue de -2,
por lo tanto,
Gordon se está acercando a la escuela
a una velocidad de 2 km por hora.
Si cuando ha pasado una hora estaba a 4 km.
entonces empezó a caminar a una distancia de 6 km.
6 km. de la escuela
y noten que es consistente
cuando empezó a caminar
estaba a 6 km. de la escuela
pasa una hora y está a 4,
pasa otra hora y está a 2
y pasa otra hora y ya llegó a la escuela.
Así que Gordon estaba a 6 km. de la escuela
cuando empezó a caminar,
que son más de los 5 km.
que separaban a Eliza de la escuela,
por lo tanto Gordon estaban más lejos que Eliza.
Giovanni, pues Giovanni cuando estaba...
había estado caminando por una hora
estaba a 5 km. de la escuela
y después de otra hora estaba a 6,
por lo tanto,
Giovanni tiene un cambio neto positivo de 1
y se está alejando de la escuela
a una velocidad de un km. por hora
de modo que cuando empezó a caminar,
debía de haber estado a 4 km de la escuela,
de este modo habría estado a 4 km.
y cada hora se habría alejado un km.
noten que también pude haber comparado
después de 3 horas contra 2 horas,
hubiera dado exactamente lo mismo,
los dos son cambios de un km.
Bueno y ¿qué de Hannah?
Hannah siempre está a 5 km.
parece que Hannah está dormida o algo así,
de modo que Hannah
ni siquiera está caminando
y por lo tanto podría asumir,
que cuando empezaron a caminar todos los demás
Hannah estaba dormida
y seguía a 5 km. de la escuela,
por lo tanto ,Hannah no estába más lejos, de hecho, Hannah estaba a la misma distancia que Eliza.
Veamos Alberto, Alberto cuando estaba a una hora
de haber empezado a caminar
estaba a 9 km. de la escuela
y después de otra hora estaba a 10.5 ,
por lo tanto,
Alberto se aleja de la escuela
a una velocidad de 1.5 km. por hora,
eso significa que en el tiempo
"t" igual a 0, Alberto estaba a,
9 menos 1.5
7.5...
¡ay! que feo 7...
7.5 km. de la escuela
que es mayor que los 5 km. de Eliza
por lo que Alberto también,
estaba más lejos que Eliza.
La respuesta correcta es Gordon y Alberto.